when I was in college I got a DUI I had
to volunteer at n folks home they were
98 I was hung over we were exactly the
same both just Shuffle down the hallway
in our pajamas some old lady's like
when's the pain going to end I'm like I
know right she's like they took away my
license I'm like same
here she's like I got an STD in this
place I was like yeah my
bad that's drinking for you it's fun but
it'll get you into trouble my friend got
really drunk one night blacked out
hooked up with somebody got herpes yeah
so he quit drinking kept the herpes
but but booze was our whole relationship
now every time we hang out he wants to
do activities wants to go horseback
riding canoeing cycling I'm like dude
just cuz you have herpes doesn't mean we
have to live out the
commercial he's like you don't get it
man I got side effects I got Suicidal
Thoughts insomnia depression I was like
maybe I have
herpes